The proof is relatively straightforward.
Recall that sigma star is
the union of the strings of size 0
with those of size 1,
with those of size 2, etc.
And our overall strategy will be just
to assign the first numbers to sigma 0.
And the next to sigma 1, and
the next to sigma 2, etc.
More formally, we can can define N sub
K to be the total number of strings
of size at most K, and then use
this to create the correspondence.
Thus, Nk will be the last number
assigned to a string of length k.
So in this way,
1 will get assigned to the empty string,
the only element of sigma 0.
And then the next number
N0+1 through N1 that'll get
assigned to all the strings of length 1.
And in general, Nk-1+1 through Nk,
those set of numbers will get assigned
to sigma k, the strings of length k.
Within each one of these arrows, you
can do the correspondence in any way.
Lexographical order is as good as any.
For example,
we can enumerate all the strings
over the binary alphabet like this.
First we assign one to the empty string,
then we enumerate
all strings of length one,
then those of length two, ans so forth.
This is the main theorem that we will
need here concerning countability.
But while we're on the subject,
we'll say a few words about countability
in general as a kind of bonus.
The same argument here,
shows that a countable union
of finite sets is countable.
Suppose that our collection
of sets is S0, S1, etc.
And without loss of generality,
we're suppose that they are disjoint.
If they happen not to be disjoint,
we can make them so
by just subtracting out from Sk.
All the elements it
shares with the sets,
s0 through Sk-1 then the argument
proceeds just as before.
We assign the first numbers to S0,
the next to S1, etc.
Now it turns out that we can actually
prove something even stronger
than the original statement here.
We can replace the word finite
with the word countable, and
say that a countable union of
countable sets is countable.
Notice that our current
proof doesn't work.
If we tried to count all of the elements
of S0 before any elements of S1.
We might never get to the elements
of S1 because S0 could be infinite,
nevertheless this theorem is true.
For convenience of notation, we'll let
the elements of SK be XK0, XK1, etc.
And then we can make each SK
a row in a grid as shown here.
Again, we can't go row by row here
because we might not ever finish
the first row if S0 is infinite.
On the other hand, we can go diagonal by
diagonal since each diagonal is finite.
The union of all the Sk is
the union of all the rows, but
it's also the same thing as
the union of all the diagonals.
Each diagonal being finite, we can apply
the original version of this theorem
to prove that a countable union
of countable sets is countable.
You can also just translate the indices
here on X into an enumeration as well.
Note that this same idea proves
that the rationals are countable.
Imagine putting all the fractions with a
one in the denominator in the first row.
All those with a two in the denominator
in the second row, all those with
three in the denominator in the third
row, and so on and so forth.